to introduce Rasmus who'll be giving our
second Talk of the day on resizable
sketches okay yeah so thanks everyone as
the title says I'm going to talk about
resizable sketches and this is basically
motivated by a gap between theory and
practice so in theory sketches are are
great they allow arbitrarily good
approximation sublinear space and so on
but you know sometimes in practice you
know it it doesn't may maybe you Miss
some some details um and what I'll focus
on today
is how you set the space
parameters so a lot of sketches most I
would say uh you space is a parameter so
when you construct the sketch you say
how much space is is it going to to use
or at least bound on the space and this
is going to be fixed for the life time
of the
sketch and then you get some accuracy as
a function of space and other pares
as we also heard in uh some some of the
previous talks um actually in practice
you might want to be able to change the
space over time to adjust the accuracy
okay and when I submitted when I decided
I want to talk about this in this
Workshop it was kind of a theoretical
practical problem I hadn't actually
talked to people who who uh who said
they had this problem but I was happy to
to learn from the people here at at at
Yahoo and it was also mentioned in Le
talkest today that actually you do want
to um resize sketches as as you go along
okay in particular you might want to
start with a very small sketch and
increase it over
[Applause]
time um yeah if you go to the data
sketches um documentation you will also
see these kind of things mentioned that
actually you can deal with sketches of
different sizes and they can be merged
and and resized and and so on and I
think this is something something that
at least hasn't consider hasn't received
a lot of um attention I think in the in
the theory
literature talk I'm going to give three
examples it's going I don't have a lot
of slides so don't don't hesitate to
interrup me with questions so the first
topic is uh expandable filters so this
is something I started working on 10
years ago so we had some theoretical
results back then that I'll talk about
and then recently we figured out how to
make this
interest and then I'm going to talk
about expandable versions of some
well-known sketches Mr regre heavy
hitter sketch and the K minimum value
sketch that can be used for various
things incl including cardinality
estimation so these are really simple um
ways of making these uh sketches
expandable they may be well known but I
haven't seen them describe in
the so let's uh let's start
yeah and there's going to be few answers
and and many questions
right all right so yeah so this
basically started when I was visiting
Microsoft research
2013 and I worked with uh Gil SE and UD
back then and what we wanted to look at
was the approximate membership Pro okay
so maybe you know about Bloom filters so
this is the problem solved by by Bloom
filter so you have some some set of of
size n and what you want to represent is
an approximation of this set so this
approximation let's call it S Prime it
should be a superet so we never want to
make errors that we think some something
is uh not in the set while it actually
it is and we want the property that we
don't overestimate too much in
particular for anything that is not in
the set the probability that included in
our estimate should be at most EP okay
so this is approximate
membership um and it was it's known
since the late
70s uh how you do this kind of in a
static setting okay so you can do this
with basically n log one over Epsilon
bits um and this is also optimal so you
can show what so this is all all good
but this requires that you know aound on
in okay um so what we start looking at
what is what if you you don't have a
bound on in right what if you know your
your set is just growing and growing and
you need to maintain this estimate over
time so you get one element at a time
and and you want to maintain kind of a
dynamic
approximation and the bad news is here
that we cannot really hope to match the
kind of the static
setting so and we're able to show a
lower bound that at some point if we
insert if we do n insertions then at
some point we have used log log n Bits
per element in s okay so at some point
we it could be early it could be late
but at some point we need s sty of s
Times log log n Bits And this is kind
ofly um and this is actually tight so
there's an upper bound that you can use
kind of what what we had
before uh this n log one/ Epsilon plus n
log log n
Bits so this was this was all nice um
but then uh yeah and actually let me
start by telling you how this works
because it's kind of the the upper bound
um so because it's it's pretty
simple so we use a hash function and for
Simplicity I'm just going to assume that
we hash to the real values between
between zero and
one and we are going to discretize this
hash function in different
ways so let's define hm as the hash
function that takes H of X multiplies it
by m and then rounds down so it
basically
discretizes H to
um bits all right so we you going to use
hash functions of this form and now in
the case where n is known
there's a a very simple way of solving
the problem optimally which is that you
use m equal to n over Epsilon so
basically you hash to a domain of size n
over Epsilon and then you store the set
of hash
values so it's n values in a range of
size n over Epsilon and information
theoretically you can do this using
basically nlog one over
Epsilon
yes um yeah and then what is this what
is the approximation well it's it
consists of all the elements that have a
hash collision with something in this in
the in s on this
function because this set has density
Epsilon the probability of a has
Collision is so this is what want um but
this requires I mean even the
description of the hash function here
requires that we know n we actually
don't need to know s in advance but we
do need to know n the number elements
that we want to end
up so what can we do I mean kind of the
obvious first idea is well why don't we
just you know hash you know increase the
range of this uh hash right so we start
with some range and then at some point
we get the we get we yeah the range is
too small and we double it all right so
we let's try M being the smallest power
of two that is big enough Okay so so the
trouble is that we don't really have the
full information to do this doubling
without losing something right so
suppose we know some hash value uh when
we have a range of size
M if you want to double the range to
size 2m well there are two possible
values right because we want to go from
the first logm significant bits of age
of x to uh log n plus one significant
right so there are basically two comp
itions and we don't know which which
which we which one we have so basically
we have to the only thing we can really
do is or hope to do is to maintain a
superet okay so we can basically put
both both posib possibilities in our
approximation uh unfortunately this
makes um the error grow so so we're not
going to be able to control kind of the
error rate here so this is the drawing
of of the situation so suppose so the
red cells here includ uh indicate the
hash values when we hash to a range of
size 16 maybe we double the range to
size
32 and then you know this hash value
here corresponds either to this or that
but we don't know which one and we need
a one side approximation so we need to
include um but then when we get further
insertions of course we can we know the
exact hash value in the in the range of
size so it's it kind of
um doesn't quite work okay because the
the fraction of uh the fraction of of
elements that actually are in the in C
hash values is is going to be larger and
larger um but there's
a slight variation that actually works
okay so we're going to be a little bit
more aggressive so we are going to
increase the or double the size of the
of
the table a little bit sooner okay
so before we said n over Epsilon now we
are going to say we are going to round
up to something that is at least n log s
n so it's just going to go slightly
super linearly
okay and it turns out that if we do this
then actually the probability of
collision is going to be become smaller
and smaller over time okay so in
particular we have these expansion
phases that where we double the the size
of the the range of the hash function
and in you can convince yourself that in
the ey expansion phase all the elements
that that are inserted there the
probability that you collide with one of
them is going to be something like I
divided by Epsilon sorry Epsilon divided
i s Okay so it decreases
um over time and this basically means
that we get the total Collision
probability is going to be the the sum
Epsilon over i^ s um and this converges
okay so we get uh we can bound the total
CIS probability
by and the space usage is is what I
claimed before because now we don't have
such as spast set but it's almost as
fast so the spacity is no longer Epsilon
but Epsilon divided by log squ n so we
need an an additional log log n Bits per
per
L these are expandable fills simply
enough right uh question from Boby um
you can't you don't have access to the
original set which you
can't sorry you don't have access to the
original set which is the reason you
need the two bits if you had access to
the original set reash everything right
thank you yes so if you had some way of
getting access having access to the
original sets you could in fact you know
recompute whatever you needed so the
lower bound crucially relies on the fact
that um you know you don't have any way
to go back all you have is is kind of
the sketch that's that's that's a great
Point thank
you
yes so it makes understand the idea so
the issue beforehand was that whenever
you're doubling the leading bid in front
whenever you double it could be either
zero one you need to label both of them
that's the picture here right right so
why
does like if I increase how Big M is
supposed to
be how does that lower the issue of like
doubling all of these yeah I mean I
guess okay so yeah so so I guess
intuition is that you that you kind of U
you make the set sparer and
sparer
um right also kind of the the the set of
new elements that you are that you are
allowing in each round is sparer and
sparer okay but then the first elements
insert are still going to have like a
very large number I mean the the firsts
I mean they're not going to disappear at
all right so they you're going to we
cannot kind of really decrease the
probability of colliding with something
that is a result of one of the early um
insertions okay got you yeah thanks yes
because you don't have the
information so just going back to an
earlier question if you're in a mode to
begin with where the sketch is quite
sparse could you keep some side
information possibly the the
identifiers alongside knowing the
sparcity rate of the array and then uh
you can do this this doubling or however
you call
it track the sparity and then as soon as
that hits a threshold then switch mode
into this type of estimation setting
yeah I think I mean that's that's uh I
think that's another way of doing it I
mean in some sense
but we are we are you
know kind of increasing the information
that we store per
elements
um over time so in order to kind of
um yeah I'm not sure how to formulate
this but but I mean
basically basically if you start
storing identifiers of of elements I
mean you you immediately get like log
bits or something right so so so I think
um you have to be a little bit
careful could you show do you have a
corresponding diagram like the above
case where you use the better
idea um
I mean this is actually I mean it looks
the same in both cases it's it's just a
question of when do you expand at what
point do you do you move to the next
okay so so the kind of the way it works
is
identical you you kind of uh I basically
each element in in in the previous sets
gets replaced or represented by two
elements in the
next and then you um go on from there
right so it's but it's it's simply it's
simply a matter of how many things do
you allow to be inserted before you the
next doubling right and this this number
is going to we're going to have to make
that number decrease slightly in each
round in order to make sure that we keep
the kind of false positive rates in in
check so isn't there a limit then to the
number of times you could do this
doubling not really not
really but of course I mean you will pay
you will pay you will pay
the logarithm of the number of doings so
that's the log log
in space cost so there is there's a
[Applause]
cost all right so yeah thanks for these
questions so all right um so this seems
I mean this is relatively simple comes
conceptually but if you think about
practical application uh there's
actually quite a few things that makes
this tricky right you need a high
performance Dynamic succinct membership
data
structure you actually also want to
support deletions in many
applications and you can I mean
everything works conceptually easy but
you need to be able to store multiset in
order to uh allow deletions because if
you if you only store a set I mean there
could be several elements with the same
hash value right so you cannot just
remove that element from the that hash
value but if you store multisets store
how many elements have this hash value
then then things actually work even with
the
lesions uh and then there's the issue of
of kind of making the all the lower
order terms
insignificant uh so it took 10 years and
help from some people from the database
community so n danan and Pedro rgo um to
actually make make this happen Okay we
we didn't work for 10 years but uh but
it it took a while and this just
appeared in sigot this this year so I
think it was quite nice to see that
eventually at least you know these
theoretical ideas had some kind of U
effect on something that is probably
useful um and I'm not going to go into
details but just to give you an idea
about what goes inside this um data
structure named the infin filter so they
are really good at uh at naming naming
stuff in the database Community um but
basically these are the this is a
picture of the sucin dictionary and you
kind of have to split it into several
parts some that are active some that are
kind of secondary and just lying around
and so forth
um periodically we get kind of the right
space usage the right update time but
annoyingly the query time for the
Practical solution that we came up with
was is a little bit off so theoretically
it's logarithmic in N almost
logarithmic in practice actually this
ratio between the logarithm of N and the
logarithm of one over Epsilon is not
that big so maybe not a huge deal um but
we actually managed
uh recently to to also find something
practical that Nails the query time to
constant now we needed a name that was
uh kind of beat infin filter that was a
little bit challenging but then we came
up with Alf filter so it's great that
there are these very very big big
numbers that
exist all right amti time B you have I'm
kind of guess that
uh for the for the new result I think we
can ALS also deti
it but I I have to double check yeah so
it's uh yeah
so related question to the amortization
Sor right here to the amortization I
remember there was this ialp 2020 paper
by watching you and two others which
also I think tackled the de amortization
do I don't know anything about how they
do it but is is anything in there
practical or was it useful in this
Infinity yeah I mean we didn't
uh we didn't use anything from that
paper I think it's more of a theoretical
paper I believe that's
also I think they they also try to get
really low low order terms I think like
nailing the the the leading leading
leading
constants um here we're kind of happy
with kind of additive ofn
bits so one more question to make make
sure I
understand um your Bloom filter is
over time is the um growth of space
sublinear no so the it's proportional
then the the space is slightly
superlinear oh in the number of elements
I see but it's sublinear in the number
of bits to describe an element if that
makes sense I'm more concerned about the
actual space consumed yeah no is little
super superlinear yes but that's that's
a lower bound saying that you cannot
hope to solve this
problem in sub linear
[Applause]
space all right thank you so let's let's
move to the next
uh sketch Mr GRE so it solves the head
heers problems um yeah so I'm just going
to look at the insertion only case we
have a stream of elements we want to
maintain information about frequen items
or heavy hits and we have some space
budget s GRE sketch is this very nice
sketch I'm sure most of you know it but
just for for completeness um basically
it stores
a set of pairs X comma LX where X is an
item from the from the input and LX is a
is a counter that is a lower Bound for
the frequency of of X okay so let's call
the true frequency
CX um and of course eventually you run
out of counters and then what you do is
you decrement all the counters and then
you throw away counters elements that
have a count of zero so very simple idea
uh but it gives you actually a very good
guarantee in particular these lower
bounds are not too far off so they are
guaranteed to be at least the true Count
minus the length of the stream divided
by S okay and this is more or less the
best you could hope to do because the
might actually be um there might
actually
be
um s elements that have a frequency of m
s all right so how can you make this
expandable well I think the natural idea
is just to allow the number of pairs to
grow and I think the way I like to think
about it is that we have faces in the
eye face we handle 2 to the I elements
and we have some space budget SI and
let's say that the space budget is is
growing over time so we want to allow
larger and larger
sketch um and then you know the argument
from Mr gree generalizes that you kind
of make the error that you made make in
the I phase is going to be number of
elements divided by Si basically so you
get this the total the total error in
your lower bounds is is this this sum 2
to the I over over
here um yeah so now we can start
choosing different values of of Si so
there there are different kinds of
trade-offs you can you can do so one
thing you could do is to
choose SI such that it's
um you know basically the length
of the face 2 to the I divided by some
Delta then to to make things converge we
actually make it a little bit bigger so
we in the ey phas we use a factor I squ
more space so that's that's one way um
this means that the space is bounded by
m log squ M divided by Delta so if Delta
is significantly larger than than log m
s that's
sublinear um and the maximum error is
going to be bounded in terms of of Delta
basically Bally because the error that
we make in each each of these spaces
like like we saw before is going to kind
of decrease fast enough that we have
conver um I don't know if this polog
factor is actually necessary or if
there's some some lower bound so that's
that's one one question here maybe more
interesting we we could uh par we could
use space that is the square root of the
length of the
okay so 2 to the I over two okay so this
means that at any time after seeing M
stream elements we use space
rotm and then actually all these bounds
also are dominated by the by the last
last term and we get kind of a an error
that is Root
in question from jly yeah on so on the
first on the previous slide I think
before you did the expandable version
your error you stated as Ms Right for
just the basic mrees yes um but you know
it's also true that the error is
like m is like the L1 Norm basically and
it's also true that you can replace that
M with like uh the L1 Norm ex ignoring
like the tail basically the L1 Norm of
of everyone except for the top s yes so
I'm wondering uh is there anything like
that that you can do for this okay
that's that's a great question I haven't
thought about it um I I don't know but
that would definitely be if if one could
get some some kind of
um yeah
residual ta
yes yeah but anyway U yeah we we use
space root M we get error rot them which
is actually optimal right so so here we
actually get get this kind of
expandability without without paying uh
kind of
an
okay so that was expandable M gree so
the final question or sorry the the
final example is K minimum value or
bottom K sketch um and I'm going to
consider the distinct elements problem
so we have the stream and we want to
maintain information about the number of
distinct items that have appeared
in and the C Val value sketch basically
maintains a sample given by a has
function so we have some hash function H
um and we maintain the elements that
have the smallest Hash Hash values so
elements that have the hash value below
some threshold to where to is chosen
such that the sample is smaller right um
and you can use this to estimate the
number of distinct elements so it turns
out that you you basically look at the
maximum hash value in your in your
sample uh and from that you can compute
a good estimator for the for the number
of distinct
elements um expandable version well I
mean kind of the obvious thing is is
just to increase the number of samples
right so the only thing is that if you
increase how big your sample can be of
course that doesn't immediately give you
more samples right so I can say that I
now I don't want 1,000 samples now I
want 2,000 samples but of course I mean
that that doesn't bring about the
samples so but what does happen is that
if you increase the bound then you can
avoid decreasing tow okay so so
basically if you increase the the bound
on the size of the sketch then at least
after some time if you see enough new
elements eventually it's going to fill
up to to
size um yeah so what can you do with
this this kind of thing so um well one
thing you might want to do is to
actually increase Precision over time so
you could maybe go for additive error
rather than multiplicative error okay so
for example maybe at time M we want to
be able to estimate the number of
distinct elements with an additive error
that is m to the
2/3 okay rather than um some kind of
relative error bound okay and why might
you want to do that well one application
I think it was also mentioned in in one
the previous talks is that if you want
to estimate set intersection so suppose
you have two such sketches and you want
to estimate the number of elements in
the intersection between the sets you
can use this uh this formula basically
to say that yeah the number of elements
in intersection is the number of the sum
of the number of elements in the sets
minus the size of
the right so if you have the sketches
you can estimate all of these three
quality quantities but the issue is is
that if you have relative error you
might not get any kind of
meaningful um guarantee if the
intersection is is is is small right so
the smaller the intersection the better
error you you want so so in particular
if I want to be able to estimate
intersection sizes that are less around
m to the 2/3 I need additive aror less
than
that and um yeah so in the expandable
version
um it seems that you can simply do do
this that you let K
grow and I'm hiding some some some
details here but conceptually this gives
you a relative error which is one plusus
one over root root K which is 1 +us M
Theus 1/3 and this gives you this
absolute error of M to the 23 I mean I'm
cheating a little bit here because it
might actually be that all the distinct
elements come early right
and then when you want you to increase
the size of the sketch you know you
don't really um you never make use of it
right um but in even in in that case you
should have an absolute error of at most
M2 okay
so I talked the title of the talk was
resizable sketches I talked about
expanding sketch size what about
reducing sketch size well it turns out
that this is much easier so that's
that's why I didn't talk much about it
so for filters if you have the hash
values with range 2m you can easily
compute the
hasas you can just decrease counters to
reduce the number of pairs he minimum
value you can decrease the threshold and
throw away things uh there also sketches
like HL that are easy to decrease the
size you can do like par par wise Max
and and so on so I think usually the
issue comes with from from expanding I
mean the the amount of information you
saw rather than
decreas okay so I think there's a lot of
open questions in this uh in this space
um one thing is that I me even though
you can do uh space size estimation with
K minimum values maybe you want to use
something better like HL um but can you
expand that and I simply don't know I
think that's a nice question to to think
about
out uh
this this uh bound I gave also depended
on the length of the stream is it
possible to get something that depends
on the number of distinct elements like
add aror that depends on the number of
distinct elements I assume not but I
don't have a lower
bound um yeah this multiplicative space
overhead for expandable mises with kind
of a bounded error is it needed or not I
don't know um and of course there are
lots of other sketching problems like
Quant tiles graphs matrices whatnot um
and I would be surprised if if kind of
adjusting sketch size wasn't you know
relevant for for some of them though I
don't know these applications too well
and then I guess also lower
bounds so that's basically what I had oh
right yeah what about Turn Style streams
delions and so on so the methods that I
had have presented don't don't deal with
that
all and that's all I have thank
[Applause]
you you can go back to your slide on the
kmv uh sketch where you show the error
so if my understanding is correct what
you're doing for these expandables
you're changing the definition of error
to be an additive error did I read that
um expandable version yeah I
mean if because kmv normally is a
relative error um exactly multiplicative
error as opposed to an additive error so
I I don't see this is the quite the
right slide maybe was the next one you
can also think about it as getting a
better and better multiplicative error I
mean that's equivalent okay so the
multiplicative error is not some fixed
one plus Epsilon but it's one plus
something that is decreasing over
time okay so that um yeah the bigger you
you set the
better approximation you want right
right yeah and you're still maintaining
that I I was little con confused by
using the word ad error I mean it's it's
maintained it's maintained as a price
right it it does does require more and
more space over time right but if your
application requires that you are able
to um have small error like for
estimating set intersections for example
then then then it might be be the only
way to do
it so then again it's not sublinear in
space
um so it's
um like a super linear no this this
would actually be I mean it depends on
how you set set the parameters but uh
but but this this one you you can make
subar if you I mean if you if the
approximation you require is not
too um it's not too good right it so
what it depends it depends on how how
how quickly do you want the
approximation to improve right if you
want the approximation to really quickly
become very good then it's linear space
right but uh but if the approximation is
is kind of more kind of uh improving
more more gently like like in this
example here then then you actually get
I mean this would get give additive
error m to the 2/3 and space m to the
2/3 okay so so both are which of which
are
subar I'm also confused why you use the
include exclude expression for your uh
intersection uh when you have
representation of all the elements
so in our experience anyway the include
exclude expression gives you much worse
error to start
with so this is this is the yeah this
this formula is is is on the on the on
the sets not on the
sketches this is on what this is on the
on the original
sets not not on on the
samples um okay but each of those each
of those terms has uh even though you
show plus and minus the error
statistically is addtive across all
those ter yeah yeah yeah I mean you get
like three times the error yeah or
something like this yeah uh that's
that's right but maybe maybe let's talk
offline I'm not sure what your concern
is yeah
[Applause]
um so you mentioned you haven't looked
at turny streams but you could consider
something like a count wi sketch just an
update only model which feels a bit
similar to your Bloom filter so have you
considered that at all there is a
student in Copenhagen who is working on
exactly that uh I'm not sure exactly
what the status is but uh but it's but
it sounds like you know a good
possibility to do something there yeah
[Music]
so for many skes their analysis is based
on the certain properties of H functions
so do you think is there any research on
resetable Construction Construction of
resetable H functions all so or the use
of certain H function make it impossible
or difficult to make the corresonding
scetches
expandable I'm sorry I I didn't quite
get the question so so so for for many
sketches like mean so yeah so Le
analysis based on certain um properties
of H functions so do you think this
there natureal connection between
expandable sketches and the construction
of certain H function make makes certain
H function Expendable ah yes I mean it's
it's true that kind of if you look at
hash table literature there's a lot of
um work on how you best expand your hash
table in order to you know minimize
space and and time and so on I mean I
mean this this basic idea of including
one extra bit is actually I mean that's
that comes from the database literature
in the 80s I I think that you can kind
of almost yeah that you can you know get
twice the number of hash values by just
adding an extra bit to each um so I
think that's that that's somehow comes
from that area it's possible that one
can transfer other ideas but I I'm not
[Applause]
sure
have you found that uh having looked at
this problem across several different
types of
sketches uh that there
are patterns or like reusable tricks in
either the algorithmic changes or the
analysis um that are maybe applicable to
different kinds of
problems uh yeah that's that's a good
question I mean Frank Frankly I haven't
worked on this that much I mean
with the exception of these expandable
filters I mean most of it is is kind of
things that have been in the back of my
mind for a while and nothing has
happened so I thought well if I give a
talk about it maybe something will
happen so um yeah so um but I'm sure
that you
know I'm sure that there are some of
these tricks that maybe have brought
applicability but uh but I wouldn't I
wouldn't know
what 2.2 in
particular thank
you
questions I had a quick question so I
love the question about the the the the
dynamic case but I want to know how
optimistic you were that things might
there might be positive results in the
dynamic case when even with inss UND
deletes it seems maybe hard because you
want Del lead to perfectly cancel off
the inserts and if you even if you
change the sketch but I what do you
think
I'm I'm cautiously optimistic that that
that something is possible at least for
some of these problems in the dynamic
case but
um um but there might there might indeed
also be lower bounds which we haven't
looked at at all probably need to allow
some false negatives
right unless you have enough information
to truly
identify what has been removed right so
for the yeah so so the question is what
about false negatives and I think it's
it is true for the for this um
approximate membership problem or filter
problem um you do need I mean to be able
to do deletions you need a promise that
whatever you delete has actually been
insert otherwise uh otherwise you're
going to have false negatives so that's
that's kind of a provable provable
there any other
questions no let's thank Rasmus once
okay
so we now have a quick break